I have 1 question for you,
what difference
you make between 1 road block by tractors
and 1 road block
by environmental activists?
What difference do you make when
at 69 for example,
1 truck catches fire,
and when you have
also trucks that catch fire
on agricultural blockades?
I can tell you
the difference on the side of repression,
it is very clear,
is that we find ourselves having to go to the tribune,
that we have ongoing lawsuits,
that we have 1 police repression which is very
very large.
And that,
for me the only difference I make,
is on the political subject,
is that we are 1
government that has
granted the right to decide on what anger
was legitimate
or not.
And so there we see 1 application
differentiate from the Republican order,
no,
it's not what anger are legitimate or not,
it is which mode of action are legitimate or not.
You pretend not to believe,
not to see that
in saint-soline we sent des des des
of the. I was asking you
in bourgabin,
I ask you 1 other question,
what are you doing?
Is that not,
but please,
what difference do you make between 1 egg block
by environmental activists and tractors?
I make 1 difference between those who throw
damage to the police,
are those who don't give it away.
This is not the case for a huge majority
Ecological protesters,
as we have seen,
we saw it just now.